à la suite du documentaire choc je ne
suis pas une [ __ ] donc je suis une
journaliste diffusé hier sur canal+
plusieurs journaux ont critiqué le choix
éditorial de la chaîne en cause des
images qui n'auraient pas été montrées
lors de la diffusion un travail de
montage effectué afin de donner toute la
parole aux femmes et rien qu'aux femmes
c'est ça a été la réponse de canal+ qui
voulait vraiment quelques les femmes moi
je vous dis j'ai eu un témoignage de
thomas villechaize qui est un très bon
pote à moi qui m'a dit moi aussi j'étais
dans le documentaire j'ai été chez hervé
mathoux également a été trois si
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux ont
dénoncé ce choix
pierre ménès lui n'a aucunement refusé
sa participation au documentaire
c'est vraiment la réponse officielle de
la chaîne de canal + et du service de
presse alors afin d'être le plus
transparent possible sur cette affaire
moi j'ai eu tous les dirigeants de
canal+ aujourd'hui et je leur ai dit la
meilleure chose à faire ce serait de
diffuser cette séquence donc touche pas
à mon poste que ce soit avec pierre donc
qui va être là qui va la regarder avec
nous avec francesca avec vous tous avec
vous au moins que vous voyez cette
séquence qui a été coupée on a choisi de
ne pas la couper au montage on a choisi
de vous la diffuser dans l'intégralité
après pierre s'expliquera là-dessus
reviendra là dessus regardez donc cette
séquence qui dure trois minutes la
séquence est très forte
voilà je vous dis la séquence est très
très fort et c'est vrai que vous allez
voir vous allez rester scotché mais
c'était bien on la voit tous ensemble et
qu on la diffuse ce soir en direct dans
touche pas à mon poste c'est cette
séquence qui a été donc non diffusé hier
et juste après pierre ménès sera fait
[Musique]
tu as une image de journaliste justement
un peu amusé jean d'un mec à poney
devine comment tu expliques tu ne les
explique pas je peux être sexiste mais
je suis quand même le seul mec qui
essayait de faire une émission foot avec
que les filles ont calé nous l'amérique
pour la
m je vous présente mes copines du soir
membres merci
jessica houara
bêtises pendant sept heures juste un peu
moins virginie faut quand même faire le
distinguo entre les choses graves et le
discours de tous les jours si on ne peut
plus rien dire à une femme parce qu'elle
est une femme je désolé ça c'est sexy ça
c'est insupportable
une fille qu'elle est jolie avec son
décolleté moi je trouve ça plutôt gentil
oui toi pour toi c'est un contenu bah
oui quand à faire d'ailleurs je remarque
qu'au niveau décolleté tu m'as pas gâtés
aujourd'hui ce cas là poursuit savais
que c'était pour moi tous avec ses mots
quand est arrivé au cfc j'étais beaucoup
chambrer mais c'est ma méthode c'est ma
méthode d'intégrer les gens fait ma
méthode de les faire exister par
évidemment les gens qui sont pas de
place je dirais toujours sur les cônes
de marie ou toujours pour les côtes de
l'ordre c'est pas du tout ccc
c'est aussi comme ça que tu intègres
quelqu'un un plateau que tu crées une
ambiance jeudi est toujours très bien
déjà les dires défendu mais tu n'as pas
besoin de te défendre parce que vous
attaquez pas est ce que tu te souviens
notamment un autre on s'était embrouillé
toi et moi il ya 4 ou 5 ans parce que tu
avais souleymane jules devant tout le
monde te souviens tu te souviens pas du
tout tu te souviens pas et pas du tout
tu vois moi je m'en souviens ouais donc
tv soulevé ma jupe et je l'avais mal
pris je t'avais même je crois frapper ou
je sais pas quoi
pas du tout mais ça par exemple est ce
que tu leur ferait aujourd'hui oui
soulever la jupe de quelqu'un comme ça
même en sachant que ça peut être
humiliant s'est fait humilier oui je
suis désolé mais
ouais mais il faut aussi prendre les
gens comme ils sont pas tous aussi pour
les gens comme ils sont
j'ai été embauchée parce que je suis un
personnage je ne joue pas un personnage
été embauché pour ça alors j'étais
peut-être soulever la jupe j'avoue je
m'en souviens absolument pas mais ce que
j'ai été incorrect avec toi une fois
balawi non non mais indépendamment de sa
non mais c'est on parle de ça s'est fait
tout ce système là qui fait que
justement une normalité c'est sûr si tu
étais un mec j'aurais pas soulever
taille ou saas et c'est évident c'est
mon côté un peu rebelle mais quand je
dis moi si je peux plus chambres et une
meuf parce que c'est une meuf
c'est insupportable à je te chante non
non je vais pas déconner avec toi tu es
une fille ça c'est pas choquant ça ça
c'est super chaud qu'on dit tellement
l'habitude d'avoir des femmes dans ma
vie professionnelle que que
moi je suis désolé je fais pas de
différence mois pour moi une femme un
homme c'est pareil